I've said it before and I will say it again
for a document summarizing and investigation
that supposedly totally clears the president.
No collusion, no obstruction, which hunt presidential
harassment, all that stuff.
Trump's going crazy to prevent the release
of the document, which supposedly totally
exonerates him.
And the big news that we learned from yesterday
is that Donald Trump is asserting now executive
privilege over the entire unredacted Mueller
report.
Uh, understand the sort of process that this
has gone through.
Trump's attorney general, William Barr released
a redacted version of the Mueller report a
couple of weeks ago, and even in its redacted
form, it was absolutely devastating to Trump.
It's cited, quote, substantial evidence of
obstruction of justice.
It found, uh, it could not exonerate Donald
Trump from obstruction of justice.
It found that of the 14 different possible
instances of obstruction, all three legal
requirements were met in eight of those 14
possible obstructive acts.
That's really, really bad.
But this was only the redacted version of
the report.
And Democrats have been working to get their
hands on the unredacted version of the report
because there was so much blacked out material
in that redacted version pages and pages.
Some pages have almost nothing other than
like the number of a footnote visible and
the source of the footnote.
Everything else completely blacked out.
So Democrats understandably are thinking if
the redacted version is this devastating to
Donald Trump and the people around him, we've
got to get our hands on an unredacted version.
And uh, William Barr has been resisting that,
uh, he has been going out of his way to stonewall
those requests at every opportunity.
And now that it's starting to look a little
dicey for William Barr, Trump has asserted
executive privilege over the entire report
in order to hide those redacted portions before
go any further.
What is executive privilege?
Executive privilege is the privilege claimed
by the president for the executive branch
of the United States government.
And that's key because it relates to coequal
branches of government.
It's the privilege of withholding information
in the public interest.
This is all coming to a head because House
Democrats are looking at holding Attorney
General William Barr in contempt of Congress
for his refusal to release to them.
The unredacted version of the report.
Trump jumping in now and asserting executive
privilege is an attempt to preempt this and
get around the entire conversation about contempt
of Congress by William Barr.
And the crazy thing about this is that the
report has endless evidence of obstruction,
which his attorney general Trump's attorney
general William Barr, is refusing to release,
which is another obstructive act.
In other words, Barr is obstructing in order
to prevent more evidence of Trump's obstruction
to be public, which now Donald Trump is compounding
by asserting executive privilege, which is
in and of itself another obstructive act,
although unlikely to be one that rises to
the level of criminality.
What does Sarah Huckabee Sanders say about
all of this?
She's saying that the people breaking the
law are the members of the house who are trying
to do oversight.
Take a look at this quote where she said yesterday
the American people see through chairman Nadler's
desperate ploy to distract from the president's.
Historically successful agenda that's a lie
and are booming economy.
Neither the White House nor attorney general
Barr will comply with chairman Nadler's unlawful
and reckless demands.
Nothing unlawful about them.
Reckless is of course, subjective faced with
Chairman Nadler's blatant abuse of power.
There is no such abuse and at the Attorney
General's request, the president has no other
option than to make a protective assertion
of executive privilege.
Almost nothing that she said is true.
I think we could agree that she used exclusively
words from the English language.
Beyond that, I don't think I would agree about
anything in that statement with Sarah Huckabee
Sanders, the president's agenda is not historically
successful.
The demands from the house are not unlawful.
They're proper legal requests.
I don't even want to talk about the Mueller
report itself here because this is about a
much bigger crisis.
The administration has flouted what is supposed
to be balanced power and checks and balances
as established by the founders of the United
States of America.
Republican indifference is allowing this to
continue coequal branches of government, right?
That requires that when Trump disregards the
framework of how those checks and balances
work, the House and Senate need to balance
it out and go beyond partisanship.
But Republicans simply refuse.
The attorney general says, Trump can legally
stop any investigation into himself.
The Justice Department says, you can't or
you don't, or you shouldn't indict a sitting
president of the United States.
What matters is they won't do it.
This is not presidential harassment.
This is a de facto presidential immunity that
goes completely outside what the founders
of the country actually wanted an intended.
If we care about what the founders wanted
and intended, which the constitutional conservative
right claims to you have to call this out
as sickening, you have to call Republican's
out for standing by and implicitly rubber
stamping it by their inaction.
And it has to end in one way, shape, or form.
Unfortunately, the most direct path to ending
it, it's probably going out and voting Trump
out in November of 2020 because there's no
evidence anyone in power on the Republican
side, uh, is going to actually take any decisive
action here.
And that's maybe the biggest tragedy of it
all.
That goes beyond the content of the Mueller
report.
It goes beyond Trump's 14 potentially obstructive
acts.
It's more about what does this mean?
It's about the basic foundations our country
is built on and I see it going nowhere.
Quite frankly.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show